did you leave Scott's new intern it's a
nice guy yeah yeah he definitely should
meet this guy why just take my word for
it yeah bring Pete in Scott where's Pete
that's Pete yeah nice dude
Pete what's your deal what's up hey man
what's going on no what's going on
I don't know Ronnie said I should meet
you yeah I said you're nice dude what's
up Ronnie how you doing man [ __ ]
fabulous I go to school the Connecticut
school broadcasting which is poly
publicise around here I'm 34 oh I'm an
old dude man I know there's somebody
says here you have Tourette's I do yes
so what do you do you blur that stuff
well you have but it's more it's more
thick it's got a tick man what did you
do what are you doing well it's like
involuntary you know [ __ ] tapes not
the cursing just no too bad we wish you
curse you'd be a superstar he moans
every once in a while don't have the
cool part of Turin he does he'll be
there writing something on the thumbs on
the desk yeah all of a sudden you hear a
gamma like the grunting [ __ ] you know
everyone you know like a volcano exactly
it's like a good chance you'll be doing
it while you're in here right now
100% oh wow I never sign no kid no
that's cool yeah you're going up and
stock around here right now good god man
I mean you know I'm 34 and I haven't
haven't really had a good date yet and
you had sex no I have not Oh 34 you
haven't got any stank on your hang low
exactly oh that's got to be frustrating
huh it is why cause it had Tourette's
and stuff you think Tourette's get in
the way you know and then like you know
where's the last time you had contact
with a woman like a kiss or a me god man
but a months ago what you do with her
like where's she now that girl I don't
usually happens like she just calls you
up and goes I don't want to see you
again
exactly she went out with her one day
was it a blind date it was kind of a
blind date yeah yeah and then you never
see her you never see her here but all
right Peter you're on my radar now don't
worry I'll be looking for you all right
I like it
thank you very much go in there
Connecticut School of Broadcasting's
Peter I like you
you